les pubs la musique la bière les plages
désertes et les caravanes tirées par des
chevaux
les premiers mots qui viennent à
l'esprit quand on évoque l'irlande sont
authenticité et dépaysement ici le temps
semble avoir pris son temps peut-être
parce que lille est le dernier pays
d'europe sur lequel chaque matin le
soleil se lève la randonnée en roulotte
ou la vie au pas des chevaux c'est une
des spécialités touristique du kerry
nous sommes dans l'ouest de l'irlande et
ce matin là à quelques mètres du bord de
mer une dizaine de jeunes américains se
préparent pour une nouvelle journée de
balade depuis trois jours déjà
ils vivent cette vie proche de la nature
est entouré de paysages mises à part
quelques voitures n'ont pas changé
depuis des siècles je suis originaire
landaise mes parents m'ont toujours
parler de la beauté de l'irlande et je
voulais venir voir par moi-même
c'est la meilleure façon d'admirer le
paysage
en tout cas c'est beaucoup mieux que
d'aller dans un bus
on va plus lentement il suffit de
regarder autour de soi américains à la
recherche de leurs racines mais aussi
visiteurs de toute l'europe à la
recherche eu de vacances différentes le
comté de kerry est encore protégé du
tourisme de masse a toujours été bons
cette année on a eu quelques difficultés
à commencer la saison à cause des
problèmes de la fièvre aphteuse
mais les efforts en ont été limités la
saison sera bonne
ambiance ici plus pour l'ambiance que
pour le beau temps plus pour les
chansons et la nature que pour être vu
on vient ici pour les irlandais les
traditions la musique et le temps de
vivre